You're running a successful company.
It's just interesting because my mind has been in that space of, uh,
potentially being one of the millions other entrepreneurs. Uh,
what's your advice on how to build a successful startup,
how to build a successful company?
I think that one thing I, I do like,
and it might be a particular thing about America, but like,
there is something about like playing,
tell people what you really want to happen in the world. Like,
don't stop it. It's not, it's not gonna make it. Um,
like if you're asking someone to invest in your company, don't say.
I think maybe one day we might make a million.
Dollars. Um, when you actually believe something else,
you actually believe you're actually more optimistic,
but you're toning down your optimism because you want to appear,
um, like low risk.
But actually it's super high risk if your company becomes mediocre
because no one wants to work at a mediocre company,
no one wants to invest in the puppy. Um, so you should play the real game.
Um, and obviously this doesn't apply to all businesses,
but if you play a venture backed startup kind of game, like play for keeps,
played a wind, go a big, um, and it's very hard to do that.
I've always feel like, um, I, yeah, I start,
you can start narrowing, narrowing your focus because 10 people are telling you,
you know,
you got to care about this boring thing that won't matter five years from now.
Right. And you should push back and do the real play the real game. So.
Be bold. So both, I mean, there's a,
there's an interesting duality there.
So there's w w the way you speak to other people about like your plans
and what you are like privately just in, in your own mind.
And maybe it's connected with what you were saying about yeah.
Sincerity as well. Like if you,
if you appear to be sincerely optimistic about something that's
big or crazy,
it it's putting yourself up to be kind of like ridiculed or something.
And so if you say my mission, my mission is to, um, yeah, go to Mars.
It's just so bonkers that, uh, it's hard to say.
It is, but, uh, uh, one powerful thing,
just like you said is if you say it and you believe it,
then actually amazing people, uh, come and work with you. Exactly.
It's not just skill, but the dreams, there's something about optimism that, uh,
that like that fire that you have when you're optimistic of actually having the
hope of building something totally cool.
Something totally new that when those people get in a room together,
like they can actually do it. Yeah. Uh, yeah. There's yeah. There's,
that's, uh, and also makes life really fun when you're in that room.
So all of that together, uh, ultimately, I don't know,
that's what makes this crazy ride of a startup really, uh,
look fun and Elis is an example of a person who succeeded that does that many
other inspiring figures, which is sad. Uh, I used to be a Google and there's,
um,
there's something that happens that sometimes when the company grows bigger and
bigger and bigger, where that kind of ambition kind of quiets down a little bit,
you know, uh,
Google had this ambition still does of making the world's information accessible
to everyone. And I remember, I don't know, that's beautiful. I,
I still love that dream of that. You know, these, the scan books,
but just in every way possible make there was information accessible.
Same with Wikipedia. Every time I open up Wikipedia, um,
I'm just awe inspired by how awesome humans are man
at creating this together. I don't know what the meetings are over there,
but they, it's just beautiful. Like what they've created is incredible.
And I'd love to be able to be part of something like that.
And you're right for that. You have to be bold.
And there's an strange to me also, I think you're right.
That there's how many boring companies they are. Right.
It's something I always talk about, especially in FinTech. It's like,
why am I excited about this? This is so lame. Like, what is this?
Isn't even like important. Even if you succeed, this is going to be like,
terrible. Like this is not good. Um,
and it's just strange how people can kind of get fake,
enthusiastic about like boring ideas when there's so
many bigger ideas that, um, yeah. I mean,
you read these things like this company raises money and it's just like,
that's a lot of money for the worst idea I've ever heard.
Some ideas are really big.
So like I worked on autonomous vehicles quite a bit.
And there's so many ways in which you can present that idea to yourself,
to the team you work with to just, yeah.
Like to yourself when you're quietly looking in the mirror in the morning, uh,
that's really boring or really exciting.
Like if you're really ambitious with the autonomous vehicles there, it,
it changes the nature of like human robot interaction is it changes the nature
of how we move, forget money. If you get all that stuff,
it changes like everything about robotics and AI machine learning.
It changes everything about manufacturing. I mean, cars,
transportation is so fundamentally connected to cars. And if that changes,
it's changing the fabric of society, of movies, of everything. Uh,
and if you go bold and take risks and go,
be willing to go bankrupt with your company, uh,
as opposed to cautiously, you can, you can really change the world.
And so sad for me to see all these autonomous companies,
Thomas vehicle companies,
they're like really more focused about fundraising and kind of like smoke and
mirrors are really afraid.
Then the entirety of their marketing is grounded in fear and presenting
enough smoke to where they keep raising funds.
So they can cautiously use technology of a previous decade or previous two
decades to kind of test vehicles here and there,
as opposed to do crazy things and go huge at scale to
huge data collection. And, um, yeah, so that's just an example,
like the idea, it can be big,
but if you don't allow yourself to take that idea and think really big with it,
uh, then you're not going to make anything happen.